-Bonjour.
-Le vivant est
au coeur de la pensée
philosophique, sociologique,
à travers sa mise en danger
par la crise climatique
et la menace
sur la biodiversité,
à travers aussi
les interrogations sur le genre,
dans son rapport au sexe,
ou à travers, finalement,
son prolongement éventuel
dans et par la machine.
Il est un peu le retour
du refoulé philosophique.
Bien sûr, la biologie a eu
son mot à dire et Darwin,
au 19e siècle, a bouleversé
le champ philosophique,
et ça tombe bien,
vous en êtes l'un des traducteurs,
en plus d'être un philosophe
spécialiste de la biologie.
Mais je le précise aussitôt,
vous êtes aussi l'auteur
d'une philosophie cyborg.
Comment passe-t-on
du vivant au cyborg ?
Est-ce qu'il y a une continuité
ou, au contraire, un continuum ?
D'ailleurs, qu'est-ce que "cyborg",
sans article défini, je précise.
-Merci pour cette question.
En effet, je dirais qu'il n'y a pas
de solution de continuité,
au sens où il faut réaliser
que la technique
est une activité vitale,
une activité derrière laquelle
il y a toujours des êtres vivants.
On peut penser bien sûr
à des choses presque quotidiennes :
les oiseaux qui font leur nid,
les araignées qui font une toile.
Eh bien la technique,
même dans ses formes
les plus élaborées,
finalement, c'est toujours,
ou en tout cas,
ça toujours été, au départ,
l'action d'un être vivant,
une stratégie
pour survivre, une manière
de développer à l'extérieur
des choses dont on n'est pas
nécessairement doté à l'intérieur.
Donc des sortes d'organes
mais qui ne sont pas
dans notre corps,
avec lesquels on ne naît pas.
On a tendance
à faire une partition
rapide entre, on va dire,
le naturel et l'artificiel.
Ca veut dire qu'il y a
quelque chose d'organique
au principe de la technique.
C'est une manière de dire :
"En fait,
"la nature produit
des artifices".
Et le cyborg,
ou la figure
de cyborg ou du cyborg,
c'est une manière de dire
que les entités
qu'on a coutume
de décrire
comme des êtres humains,
eh bien ces êtres humains-là,
ce ne sont pas uniquement
des êtres biologiques.
Ils ont une dimension culturelle,
voire technique, qui leur est
nécessairement intégrée.
Donc il n'y a jamais
d'humain "nu",
d'humain qui serait
entièrement démuni.
Il y a toujours des extensions,
des compléments techniques,
qui sont présents,
qui sont consubstantiels
à l'identité humaine,
et je pense
que c'est l'un des sens qu'on peut
donner à cette entité, cyborg :
à la fois cybernétique
et organique.
C'est-à-dire, une sorte
de mélange inséparable, en fait,
entre des éléments organiques
et des éléments techniques.
-Ca remet en question
les dualismes
qui ont longtemps
structuré la pensée.
Commençons peut-être
par la nature
et la technique.
"La nature a bon dos", vous dites,
"et elle se fait normative
"de façon très abusive",
mais en même temps,
vous ne voulez pas renoncer
à la biologie.
Quelle place tiendrait
la biologie ?
Dans certaines
théories du genre,
on va jusqu'à nier
la réalité du sexe.
Qu'est-ce que le sexe ?
Est-ce que le sexe existe ?
Quelle place doit tenir la biologie
dans un discours philosophique ?
-Pourquoi ne pas renoncer
à la biologie ?
Parce que je pense
que nous ne sommes pas
au principe de toute nos actions.
Nous aimerions, par notre volonté,
par notre intelligence,
par nos désirs,
transformer entièrement la réalité
selon nos conceptions.
Mais en fait, on s'aperçoit
que l'aventure vitale,
c'est quelque chose
dans laquelle nous sommes pris,
nous sommes emportés,
quelque chose qui nous traverse,
et donc il y a plein d'éléments
de notre existence sur lesquels
nous n'avons pas la main.
Nous ne savons pas encore
faire naître et se développer
des cellules,
en tout cas, ex nihilo,
à partir d'éléments inertes.
Nous sommes obligés de recourir
à des dispositifs déjà existants,
déjà vivants, pour engendrer la vie.
Et cette vie, on voit bien
qu'elle n'est jamais stable,
que c'est un processus
qui nous emporte,
qui nous traverse,
qui nous prend, qui nous constitue
et qui nous dépose.
Contre ça, on a beau protester,
on a beau s'efforcer,
on n'y peut pas grand-chose,
et je crois que c'est important
de prendre en compte
cet élément
de résistance,
cet élément d'impuissance,
mais également cette spontanéité
du vivant, en fait.
Donc la nature se fait
abusivement normative
parce que la nature
est essentiellement normative.
En dépit du fait
que nous soyons
des êtres de culture,
des êtres de pensée,
nous appartenons aussi
à cette grande aventure
du vivant,
dont nous sommes
une forme, un dépôt...
-Et dont la technique
serait donc une extension ?
-Absolument, voilà.
Après, on peut faire
avec Bergson une distinction
entre des techniques
presque organiques
- la toile d'araignée
que j'ai évoquée -
et puis une technique
qui serait le produit
de l'intelligence,
d'une projection extérieure,
et moins arrimée
à l'organisme.
-Donc on n'a pas à se méfier
comme on le fait souvent,
de l'intelligence artificielle,
de la technique
qui vient dominer les hommes ?
Est-ce que cette césure
peut avoir lieu,
ou, au contraire,
il faut réussir à la réinscrire
dans l'aventure du vivant ?
Comment on fait avec ça ?
Parlons peut-être du transhumanisme
et du posthumanisme,
qui sont d'ailleurs
deux concepts différents,
si vous pouvez revenir.
-En effet,
avec ce que j'ai dit,
que la technique est toujours
organique dans son origine,
on a l'impression qu'il n'y a jamais
de problème avec la technique,
et que du coup, on pourrait
dire que le simple fait
d'avoir des lunettes,
voire d'avoir un langage
fait de nous des êtres équipés,
donc des êtres déjà artificiels,
donc déjà peut-être des cyborgs.
Je crois qu'ici,
on rate quelque chose,
et on rate le fait qu'effectivement,
le terme de cyborg,
il n'est pas juste descriptif.
Il comporte une forme
d'appréhension, en fait.
C'est ce que vous exprimiez,
c'est-à-dire l'idée
que la technique va nous dominer
au lieu d'être faite pour nous,
d'être soumise à nos fins.
Et cette idée-là, cette technique,
on pourrait dire "prédatrice",
qui, au lieu de prolonger
la chair vivante,
au contraire,
utilise la chair vivante.
Nous sommes un peu les organes
de reproduction des machines,
et ça a quelque chose d'inquiétant.
Ca, il faut le prendre en compte.
C'est pour ça
que je distinguerais
ce que j'ai appelé organorg,
c'est-à-dire
des organismes outillés,
simplement,
de la figure véritable du cyborg,
qui comporte
une dimension d'appréhension,
une dimension de terreur, même.
C'est-à-dire la terreur
de voir l'instrument se retourner
contre son créateur, voire le moyen
de devenir fin pour lui-même.
Aujourd'hui,
nous ne sommes plus en mesure
de contrôler nos instruments.
Si on conçoit la technique
comme un marteau,
on voit bien qu'on peut le prendre,
le poser, le reprendre...
Même la lumière,
on a l'impression qu'on peut encore
actionner l'interrupteur,
et puis éteindre l'appareil,
s'en passer.
Les instruments techniques
auxquels nous nous rapportons
de manière isolée
les uns avec les autres
- vous avez la voiture, le frigo,
ce que vous voulez -
font système.
Par exemple, le système électrique,
tout simplement,
est quelque chose qui exige
des conditions de production...
"grandioses", j'allais dire,
bien au-delà de notre échelle,
et que pour tout fonctionne
ou continue à fonctionner,
il faut des infrastructures
qui sont terrifiantes
dans leur ampleur :
une centrale nucléaire,
une centrale à charbon,
dont on voit,
dont on mesure aujourd'hui
l'impact global.
Donc la question de l'interrupteur
est essentielle.
On voit bien que,
si on y réfléchit bien,
il n'y a plus d'interrupteur.
Par exemple, sans électricité,
il n'y aurait plus
de circulation possible :
de feu de signalisation.
Ce serait le chaos général.
Donc l'interrupteur
n'existe plus.
On voit qu'il n'y a pas
de marche arrière,
sauf à revenir, si vous voulez,
à une sorte de naturisme,
je vais dire, cette fois,
c'est-à-dire de figure
où nous serions réduits
à notre propre nudité.
J'allais dire nullité.
-On est dans le posthumanisme ?
Comment le qualifierait ?
-En fait,
je dirais que l'être humain
n'a pas de nature.
-Oui.
-L'être humain toujours été équipé,
d'une certaine manière.
-C'est une question de quoi ?
De quantité,
de passage à la limite ?
Est-ce qu'un moment donné,
cet outillage
ne devient pas
qualitativement différent,
et ne change pas de sens
tout simplement ?
-Je crois qu'il y a
une vraie question de savoir
jusqu'à quand nous sommes humains.
Là, il y a
une question de curseur.
On peut l'être un peu plus,
un peu moins.
C'est quoi, être humain ?
-Bonne question. Vous avez consacré
tout un livre
sur le "presque" humain.
Revenons sur ce "presque".
Ca peut être l'animal,
ça peut être le monstre,
dans la littérature fantastique,
ça peut être l'extraterrestre,
ça peut être la machine...
Revenons sur ce "presque",
qui dit en creux
ce que n'est pas,
ou ce que devrait être l'humain,
ou le fait que l'humain
ne peut simplement pas être défini.
-Si on part de ça,
la difficulté à saisir
le propre de l'humain montre
que l'humain n'existe pas
comme une espèce naturelle
qu'on pourrait simplement décrire
par ses propriétés anatomiques,
mais que les êtres humains sont
toujours, je dirais, au potentiel.
Donc de manière nécessaire,
on est plus ou moins humain,
et on est plus ou moins humain
tous et toutes,
à un certain moment, mais on est
également plus ou moins humain,
chacun de nous, à différents moments
de notre existence,
et même à différents moments
de la journée.
En fait, il est très facile
de basculer
du sentiment d'être
humain plein et entier
à, au contraire, le sentiment
d'être sorti de l'humanité,
ou d'être traité
comme moins qu'humain.
Voilà, donc cette question de degré,
cette question de curseur
qui est extrêmement subtile
et difficile à maîtriser,
elle montre que l'humain
est, en vérité,
une entité qui doit
toujours s'actualiser.
-La question de l'humain se pose
dans la reconnaissance de l'autre.
A quel moment je reconnais
que l'autre est un humain
ou autre chose, un infrahumain,
ou une machine ? D'ailleurs,
vous reprenez
la fameuse description
de Descartes sur :
"Lorsque je vois des chapeaux
"et des manteaux
à travers la fenêtre,
"est-ce que ce sont des hommes
ou des automates ?"
C'est une expérience vertigineuse.
Quelle est cette question
de la reconnaissance ?
Comment on peut la reposer
à travers votre propre outillage
philosophique ?
-Alors...
-C'est une question
essentiellement politique,
mais ce qui est frappant,
c'est de voir comment,
aux portes de l'humain,
ne cessent de frapper,
de s'adresser
de nouvelles demandes ?
On n'en a jamais fini, finalement,
avec ce dialogue infini
que l'humain doit entretenir,
non seulement avec ceux
qu'il reconnaît comme humain,
ceux qu'il devrait reconnaître
comme humain et qu'il ne traite pas
comme humain, tout en admettant
la différence
entre les humains
et les autres,
les obligations
qui sont dues à ces autres.
Donc je pense ici
aux animaux non-humains,
je pense ici
aux écosystèmes,
aux fleuves, aux rivières,
aux forêts, etc.
Il ne s'agit pas d'inclure
tout le monde dans l'humanité,
mais l'humanité,
elle se pose des questions
éthiques et politiques, et qui,
à ce titre, doivent être traitées.
Donc je pense qu'ici,
la biologie,
elle est en quelque sorte
hors sujet,
au sens où ce n'est pas
parce que quelqu'un n'est pas humain
qu'il faut le piétiner,
ou que quelque chose
n'est pas humain
qu'il faudrait l'anéantir.
-Donc en dehors de la biologie,
il y a quand même
une décision qui est prise.
D'ailleurs,
la définition de l'homme,
elle évolue
en fonction des propres,
et donc cette évolution,
elle est liée à quoi ?
A des décisions philosophiques,
politiques ?
-Ca, c'est très intéressant,
je pense,
au sens où on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a certaines questions
- et certaines seulement -
sur lesquelles on considère
qu'on doit se régler
sur le naturel
et sur le biologique.
J'appelle ça le biologisme
car c'est ce que propose
la biologie,
quand on s'intéresse, par exemple,
à nos pensées. On va vous dire :
"Il y a des gènes, des neurones...
"Il y a des choses
qui se passent dans votre corps
"qui correspondent
à toutes vos pensées".
Donc d'une part, ça vient
des biologistes, le biologisme.
Mais ce qui est très intéressant,
c'est que ça vient aussi
fortement de la société :
il y a, dans la société,
des aspirations à régler
un certain nombre
de questions en s'appuyant
sur des données biologiques.
Donc ce biologisme, je dirais,
c'est la manière
dont la société aspire
à se trouver
légitime et fondée
dans ou par
des caractéristiques naturelles.
Ca concerne évidemment,
par exemple,
la relation qu'on a
avec les autres animaux.
Ca concerne également la question
de la différence des sexes,
au premier chef, je dirais,
parce qu'on pourrait dire
que dans l'essentiel
de ces déterminations sociales,
les êtres humains
se moquent de savoir
si c'est naturel ou pas
de construire des voitures,
des tribunaux
ou d'aller
dans des musées d'art.
Mais il y a des choses
sur lesquelles on se dit :
"Ah, mais en fait, ce n'est pas
si étranger à l'affaire,
"le fait que nous soyons
des animaux, finalement."
Et tout à coup, alors là, revient,
vous parliez de retour du refoulé,
là, le refoulé sexuel,
le refoulé biologique
nous revient en pleine face,
c'est-à-dire on se dit qu'au fond,
pour régler la question
de nos affaires
de sexe, de genres, de relations
au sein de la société,
il nous faut nous appuyer
sur une base biologique
et naturelle.
-La nature n'est pas prescriptive,
mais on ne peut pas non plus
complètement se débarrasser
de l'idée qu'il y a des sexes.
Peut-être pas deux, je ne sais pas.
Il y a combien de sexes ?
-"Il y a combien de sexes",
en fait,
ce qui est intéressant
sur la question de définir le sexe,
c'est qu'on croit bien savoir
ce que c'est,
on a le sentiment que la science
confirme ce qu'on sait.
Ca, c'est déjà frappant.
On pense qu'il y a deux sexes
et la biologie vient
et nous montre qu'il y a deux sexes.
La manière dont nous conceptualisons
le sexe, les sexes,
elle est récente.
Elle est récente,
elle n'a pas toujours eu lieu.
Au 16e, on parlait
de la théorie des humeurs,
qui nous vient
de l'Antiquité, etc.
-On parlait
quand même d'hommes
et de femmes aussi.
Le sexe, ça fait signe
vers des réalités différentes.
-Oui.
Justement,
sur cette question.
Simone de Beauvoir,
dans "Le deuxième sexe", dit :
"On ne naît pas femme,
on le devient."
Est-ce que ça s'applique
à "on ne naît pas homme,
on le devient" ?
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire,
sur la manière
dont on doit comprendre
les mots femme et homme ?
Femme,
est-ce la femelle de l'espèce
et homme,
le mâle de l'espèce ?
Est-ce que c'est juste ça ?
Parce qu'à ce moment-là,
vous comprenez,
en fonction
de ce qu'on va entendre par là,
le sens de la phrase
de Beauvoir change.
Il hésite.
Est-ce que être femme,
c'est être femelle,
et donc il faut attendre
la capacité reproductive
pour être vraiment femme ?
Ce n'est pas son propos.
-Non, je ne crois pas.
-Ce qui est clair ici,
c'est que par homme et femme,
on entend autre chose
que mâle et femelle,
ce qui est dur
à comprendre
parce qu'on n'entend aussi pas
autre chose que ça.
Il hésite.
Ce sexe dont on parle,
quand on voit des personnes
dans la rue,
on leur attribue spontanément,
on va dire, un genre, on dit.
Mais de fait,
on n'a accès à aucun déterminant
biologique du sexe.
La plupart du temps,
on ne voit pas
les parties génitales,
et surtout pas
la composition des cellules,
le caryotype, etc.
Donc en fait,
on fait un ensemble...
...d'inférences à partir
d'indices qui sont envoyés.
Voilà. Mais biologiquement,
comment ça se passe ?
Le sexe d'une personne
peut être défini
par le type de gamètes
qu'elle produit,
mais ça ne suffit pas,
par une composition de ses cellules,
les fameux chromosomes X et Y.
Il hésite.
Mais ça peut être aussi,
voilà,
une certaine anatomie
des parties génitales
et, comment dire,
des conduits internes.
Il y a énormément
de déterminants, en fait,
dans ce qui fait le sexe
d'une personne humaine,
et non pas seulement la dimension
simplement reproductive.
Donc c'est en ce sens qu'on peut
dire qu'il y a plus de deux sexes.
Si on considère simplement le fait
que pour faire un enfant,
oui, il faut deux gamètes
qu'il faut réunir,
il y en a un
qu'on appelle le spermatozoïde
et l'autre l'ovule,
et que ces gamètes sont
en général produit
par des individus différents
dans notre espèce
qu'on appelle les mâles
et les femelles.
Mais au-delà de ça,
la plupart de nos usages du sexe,
en fait, n'impliquent pas
cette dimension reproductive,
ça se situe
sur d'autres plans.
Quand nous nous adressons
l'un à l'autre,
en quoi est-ce que notre sexe
est vraiment le caractère
opératoire de la discussion ?
C'est difficile de s'en tenir
à cette notion de sexe,
c'est difficile de voir
ce qu'elle implique,
ce en quoi elle nous oblige.
-Celle de genre aussi
est étriquée ?
-Bon alors,
la notion de genre...
Vous me lancez sur un truc...
C'est trop compliqué.
Comment le dire ?
On peut dire qu'il y a
autant de genres que de personnes :
les gens s'identifient
à des grands genres
et que ça peut être
homme et femme
ou masculin et féminin,
admettons ça.
Mais en fait,
on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui,
dans les études sur le genre,
on va dire que le genre,
c'est le grand dispositif
qui fait que les individus humains
se rangent dans deux catégories
et seulement deux, voilà.
Donc c'est cette matrice binaire
qui assigne les individus
à être d'une part ou de l'autre
du grand système.
Voilà ce que l'on va appeler
le genre, dans ce sens,
il y a le genre
qui commande deux cases.
Voilà.
-Et alors Adam et Eve ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on a envoyé
dans l'espace
la représentation de l'humanité
à travers
la figuration d'Adam
et Eve, un peu en deçà ?
-Ce qui est très intéressant,
c'est effectivement
que nous avons
une sorte de mythologie des sexes
qui traverse
nos représentations.
Et nous sommes extrêmement attachés
à cette mythologie,
elle nous paraît
constitutive et descriptive
de notre réalité.
On voit bien cependant
qu'il y a
dans toute cette mythologie
un ensemble de valeurs
qui sont impliquées.
Et sur ce point, je dirais
que je n'ai pas de problème
avec les dualismes
dans la mesure
où ce sont des instruments
de pensée.
Ils nous permettent de nous situer,
ils nous permettent à la fois
de distinguer
deux grandes polarités,
mais aussi de voir
ce qui est entre les deux.
Mais le problème avec...
disons ce qui ne serait pas
simplement des binarismes, du deux,
mais des dualismes,
c'est qu'on est justement
dans le cadre d'une valorisation
différenciée des deux.
C'est pas juste
qu'on a la main gauche et la droite,
c'est que
dans beaucoup de cultures,
la gauche est le symbole
de l'infamie,
de l'impur, etc.
Dans la différence des sexes,
ce n'est pas simplement
qu'il y a deux
et qu'ils contribuent différemment
à la tâche de la reproduction,
ou à différentes occupations.
C'est que l'un est infériorisé
par rapport à l'autre.
-Comment vous comprenez
cette articulation qui n'est pas...
elle n'a rien,
finalement, de nécessaire,
entre la dualité
et la hiérarchie ?
-Sur le récit d'Adam et Eve,
on voit que, par exemple,
il y a des questions de traduction.
Catherine Chalier
l'a démontré.
Quand on a dit que Eve
était sortie de la côte d'Adam,
voilà, ça montre bien
une sorte, très clairement,
l'un est l'origine de l'autre.
Il hésite.
Alors, Chalier a montré que non,
il faut peut-être dire
qu'elle est sortie "du côté de",
comme une sorte
de processus de dédoublement,
comme deux cellules
se divisent, un peu.
Ce n'est pas exactement
la même chose,
en termes, vous voyez,
de hiérarchie.
Donc il y a des récits qui sont
peut-être coupables, fautifs,
et puis, en fait, surtout,
je dirais simplement,
il y a des dispositifs sociaux
qui infériorisent les femmes
dans les sociétés.
-Il y a une forme de quasi
universalité de ces dispositifs.
-Voilà, donc ça,
il faut en être conscient,
c'est-à-dire indépendamment
de ce que sont les personnes,
je dirais qu'il y a
les systèmes de droit
qui régissent les existences,
qui sont à la base
d'un ensemble d'inégalités,
et ça, c'est très important
parce qu'autant
que les individus,
soient tous différents
les uns des autres
et on va dire,
inégalement aptes
à assurer
telle ou telle tâche,
ça, on est habitué.
C'est le principe même
de la politique,
on est habitué à gérer
la diversité des êtres humains.
Mais en revanche,
ce qui n'est pas aussi clair,
c'est, bah voilà, la façon
dont nous désirons l'inégalité,
nous voulons
asseoir l'inégalité
dans des dispositifs juridiques,
en fait.
Donc ici, il y a une véritable
responsabilité des êtres humains,
c'est-à-dire nous ne sommes pas
responsables de notre diversité.
Nous sommes responsables
de la manière
dont nous traitons
inégalement les personnes.
Et ici, autant, moi,
je trouve que le travail
de catégorisation est essentiel
à l'activité de pensée humaine,
autant je pense
qu'il y a des catégories
meilleures que d'autres,
des catégories qui sont plus justes
ou plus injustes que d'autres.
-Pourtant, on assiste
aujourd'hui au grand retour
de l'identité,
comme catégorie politique,
et qui joue à plusieurs niveaux.
Comment on lutte
contre cette idée d'identité ?
Tout votre travail,
en tout cas,
est une attaque
contre l'idée d'identité.
Des polarités pour la pensée,
oui, mais pas fixes,
des catégories de pensée
à condition qu'elles soient pas
réifiées en catégories d'êtres.
Comment on lutte
contre l'identité ?
Comment se débarrasser
de cette question ?
-J'ai proposé
quelque chose d'assez simple,
en fait, et d'assez bête,
trop bête pour être suivi,
sans doute,
mais simplement dire,
et si nous nous efforcions
d'être humains,
de temps en temps, en fait ?
Et si nous nous efforcions de nous
situer, au-delà de nos identités,
et de nous atteler à des tâches
qui nous engagent
en tant qu'êtres humains ?
-Et pas en tant qu'homme,
que femme,
en tant que je ne sais pas,
Auvergnat,
ou Chinois, ou...
C'est l'idée d'être humain,
c'est ça que vous entendez.
-Je trouve qu'il y a des activités
qui nous placent à ce niveau-là.
L'activité des sciences,
en théorie,
c'est une de ses activités-là.
Voilà.
Face au calcul,
on est tous égaux,
entre guillemets.
Le résultat ne va pas varier
en fonction de qui je suis.
Et ça, je trouve
que c'est reposant.
C'est ce que réclamait Beauvoir
dans "Le deuxième sexe",
Le droit de participer
à des activités où on n'est pas jugé
selon ses déterminants
sociaux, historiques,
sexuels, etc.
Cette capacité
que nous avons
de nous élever à un niveau,
j'allais dire,
d'indifférence,
s'en remettre à un ordre
qui n'est pas...
qui n'est pas politique,
pour une fois.
Je crois qu'aujourd'hui,
voilà, on a le sentiment
d'une telle inflation du politique,
à juste titre,
et certaines questions
sont politiques
et ne peuvent pas être traitées
en dehors de ce politique,
mais la science,
elle nous apporte justement
en un sens un territoire
à investir dans lequel,
eh bien, nous pouvons être
autre chose que nous-mêmes.
Et c'est très important,
je crois, de s'oublier parfois.
C'est peut-être ça qui boucle,
sur l'idée, pourquoi la biologie.
Evidemment, elle a plein de défauts.
Elle est traversée de biais,
elle est dépendante des instruments
qu'elle met en place.
Elle pose des questions aussi
qui parfois sont fautives,
comme la question raciale,
par exemple,
l'a été au 19e siècle.
On a voulu fonder
dans des déterminants anatomiques
la différence des individus.
La biologie est fautive,
elle peut être défaillante, parfois.
Mais malgré tout,
elle a une aspiration scientifique.
Et ça, c'est magnifique.
D'une part,
parce que ça nous situe
sur ce territoire,
on va dire,
au-delà du politique.
Ca nous met idéalement
en prise avec des réalités,
et puis c'est magnifique aussi
parce que ça nous décentre
par rapport à notre statut d'humain.
Faire de la biologie, précisément,
ce n'est pas faire
que de la médecine.
Faire de la biologie,
c'est s'intéresser au fait
que les êtres humains
sont pris dans l'ensemble
de la biodiversité humaine.
Face à cette diversité naturelle,
nous ne sommes pas souverains.
Nous ne sommes pas en mesure
de donner les noms
qu'il nous plaît.
Il y a une histoire dont nous sommes
tenus de tenir compte
quand nous nommons,
classons et ordonnons.
C'est donc aussi
une école de modestie
pour les êtres humains,
au sens où d'une part,
les humains comprennent
qu'ils ne sont pas seuls,
qu'ils font partie
d'un écosystème beaucoup plus vaste,
mais aussi
une école de modestie,
au sens où l'esprit souverain
doit, quand il étudie la nature,
eh bien, se soumettre
à des réalités qui lui résistent.
Et ça, c'est passionnant.
Et je crois que
c'est quelque chose
qu'on apprend
quand on s'intéresse,
justement, je veux dire,
même pas à la biologie,
mais à l'histoire naturelle,
c'est-à-dire, voilà,
à simplement l'étude modeste
de l'herborisation,
de l'observation
de l'ensemble des vivants,
avec leur diversité
de modes de vie,
leur diversité de formes,
d'apparences, de devenirs.
C'est fascinant.
-Merci beaucoup,
Thierry Hocquet.
-Merci de votre entretien.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
...